infinity
both can and
can't be found
this is what simultaneity is
this and that
not this or that
obviously
you are already it
i am already it we are already
it we are the fish in
the ocean already the diamond is
already around our necks as rumi said
god is the seer you are already
infinite consciousness infinite
awareness itself
experiencing these dreamed creation
designs
you're already whole
of course then the sufi metaphysic
as we see here in point number one
a thousand years
being communicated only the
ignorant will seek what's
already there the diamond
already around our necks the seer
that we already are we're seeking
peace and happiness externally
in maya in the intoxication in the
illusion
in objects in experiences
in relationships and substances
what the parable of the prodigal son
will tell us is that the turn inward
towards our infinitude towards
recognizing that god rely state of
eternal shared awareness
that is fundamental
that is the second part of the sufi
metaphysic
which goes yet it remains
for you to recognize it
my current on
neo advaita and
non-dualism
is that it must be strategically
simultaneous
it must know how to both
say there is nothing to seek you
already are infinity infinity can't be
found
and then for it to also say that
there is a path that buddha has taught
for
2 500 years to eradicate
suffering to stop with the
craving and the aversion
to recognize the tool of breath that we
keep with us
all the time
to leverage that tool as patanjali
said in his yoga sutras yoga's chitta
vritti nirodha
to use breath to undergo union
with the infinite by quieting the
fluctuations of mind
infinity both can't be found
because you're already the fish in the
freaking ocean
duh
and yet infinity also can be found
that's the turn inward that's
these different perennial mystic
traditions
that teach people how to undergo the
process
rapidly with the direct path and with
aphorisms and retreats and books
we can rocket the processes with vr
and pedagogies for kids all this type of
stuff
the indigenous cultures around the
planet already
never even allow their infants
to undergo the process of forming the
amkara the identification with an egoic
finite contracted separate biological
entity
so they never even have to do the turn
inward
and that's what conscious parenting is
versus ignorant parenting
you both are already in the ocean
you already are infinite so you
technically can't find
infinity because you're already it and
yet
at the same time simultaneously
the dualistic concession is that
to actually recognize that diamond
necklace that is around your neck
truly to understand the eternal shared
observer
it's really important to recognize that
because you can't just stop
i imagine myself six years ago hearing
that
there's nothing to seek just stop
you already are infinite this is a dream
the individual is an illusion
and i just imagine the amount of people
that are being
attracted to a teaching that is telling
them that you're already whole
stop seeking
and then to have never undergone the
process
of theravada buddhism or dzokchen
or the daodaching or the sufi
metaphysics that have never read a line
by rumi
to have never taken an entheogen to have
never even microdosed with magic
mushrooms that have a billion years of
intelligence just because
somebody in the neo advaita tradition
said
that there's nothing for you to do
you're already it
and then for that same person to still
have
anger and frustration and craving and
aversion and to
accidentally catalyze malevolence on
their family their friends
their spouse their kids their co-workers
the community in the world
because they've never actually went on
the inward path
they've only intellectually understood
that they are
already whole that this is already
non-duality
that this is already a dream and the
individual is already illusory so
there's nothing to seek
nothing to do it completely throws away
all of greece greece was
so adamant two thousand plus years ago
about
virtue virtue means
moral excellence
read the analects by confucius
the ten commandments the noble eightfold
path
neoadvita accidentally throws away
all morality all
repetitions that have to be done at the
gym
to become truly aware of awareness
itself to become truly aware
of the eternal shared observer
that is even itself dreamed
to become aware of buddhahood
aware of the fact that buddhahood still
remains
that the process of using your
breath to quiet your mind to eradicate
misery suffering aversion and craving
that that remains so that you can
butterfly effect and domino
affect your family your friends your
spouse your
kids your co-workers the community the
world with
positive meta loving kindness
even if it's intellectually understood
that this is a dream and the individual
is
there's no guarantee that
the realization of
the eternal shared witness
happens there's no guarantee of moral
excellence of virtue
it's not okay to be
both quote non-dual and
be angry and frustrated and malevolent
at the same time
and non-duality will say things like oh
there's no values
so malevolence isn't any better
than prosperity
which on the ultimate sense is true but
in the dualistic concession
we recognize that there is prosperity
there is the eradication of suffering
there
is a billion people that still feel the
experience of not
having a safe consistent source of clean
water
and clean food and shelter and
sustainable electricity
the simultaneity here is the key
you are both a dreamed illusion as an
individual yet you are
also a unique expression of infinity
this is the thing non-dual dual
individuation
simultaneity the individual
in the ultimate sense is absolutely a
dreamed
illusion totally
there is only one non-dual awareness
that's undergoing this entire process
there's one infinite creator
undergoing this process and even the
observer
is the last thorn
to pluck out to recognize the agentless
absolute
but that remains
that although the individual is dreamed
in its illusory
simultaneously the individual is a
unique expression of infinity
the trick is to be able to juggle all of
this at the same
time the non-dual absolute
infinite perfection of everything and
the dualistic concession
where you recognize that there is
a piercing of a veilless veil walking
through a gateless gate to happen
for you to recognize that eternal shared
awareness
you literally can't just throw away
thousands of
years of planetary perennial wisdoms and
mystic traditions
because you hear in one sought song
that there's nothing to seek
you're gonna throw away the billions of
years of intelligence across the
collective
entheogenic evolution across the planet
and never imbibe because
you heard an assad song that there's
nothing to seek
the simultaneity is so key
again only the ignorant
seek what is already there
the diamond is already around our necks
we are already god the seer
got it the infinite can't be found
because i am
already infinity expressing itself i am
already the fish in the ocean got it
simultaneously
the dualistic concession is that
yet it remains for you to recognize it
do you actually know the diamond around
your neck
do you know you're the fish in the ocean
do you know yourself as the one infinite
creator expressing itself
do you know the feeling of eternal
shared awareness
do you know the feeling of liberation
of what it feels like when something
occurs in the dreamed creation design
and you have practiced so much
creating the pause that you don't just
react with anger and frustration
but that you know how to take the breath
and be the witness of the cloud be the
observer
of the experience and bring wisdom and
grace to it
or to step away from it
that requires the trainings that have
been taught in the planetary mystic
traditions
so again the non-dual
only the ignorant seek what's there the
dualistic concession
yet it remains for you to recognize it
for you to
pierce the veiless veil to the eternal
shared awareness
for you to undergo the process of
buddhahood
to eradicate suffering the roots
in your own psyche into butterfly effect
out peace happiness and well-being
in that tantric path weaving your
realizations
sahaja samadhi into the social fabric
architecting prosperity and abundance
celebrating the individual while also
recognizing it is a dream delusion
this one seems so hard for the east
i don't know why the east is
very attached in many ways and
communicators of the
eastern mystic traditions are very
attached to non-duality meaning the
complete obliteration
of the individual
it's both that the individual is a dream
delusion the obliteration of it while
it's also
celebrated as a unique firework
a unique expression of infinity
to completely reject the uniqueness
of the iris around every single one of
our pupils
is a mistake
the west for 500 plus years
has made the individual into
a incredible part
of our dreamed creation design
and to completely reject that is a huge
mistake
i literally feel jordan peterson getting
angry right now
he was a massive influence on my
awareness to that since 2017 and beyond
and many other people awakening to that
right now as well
you look at people like elon musk that
dedicated their
entire last almost two decades
to building the companies
that are enabling the sustainable
progress
of civilization and the thousands of
people that work at those companies
and you never once think to yourself
thank goodness for the fireworks of
those individuals that are doing what
they're doing
because you're stuck in the sole
non-dual awareness
you both recognize that the pupil itself
is a unique shared
observer while simultaneously
the iris is an artistic expression of
that observer
into the creation design
anybody that has been a genius level
before
us today any of the greatest spiritual
leaders
scientists engineers anybody
that has made profound impact has done
it from a place of
infinity has done it from a place of
non-duality
has done it from there because
everything is ultimately happening from
that source
from that eternal shared awareness
but they're a unique expression of that
and to forget about the unique
expression of that is a big mistake
to not celebrate the individual is a
mistake
to only recognize it as a dream delusion
is a mistake
it's not simultaneity you have to have
simultaneity
you have to know how to navigate all of
the layers of the conversation of the
dialectic
that's why dialectical monism or the
taijitsu
again jiaodunyi a thousand years ago
puts together the symbol and even the
symbol appears
in cultures around our planet as well
independently
of the taijitsu the demonism with the
duel
yin yang in it and if you imagine the
symphony in that with all eight billion
of us uniquely contributing
to the attractor that is the godhead
that is this but to only say nondual is
to only recognize monism
and to say non-duality and
simultaneously duality the yin and yang
in that tajittu that's already been here
for a thousand years
that neo advaita and modern satsang
movement is rejecting
is to also recognize that there is
suffering and there's well-being
we want to eradicate our own suffering
and maximize planetary well-being
we want to also recognize ourselves
that diamond necklace around our neck as
the one infinite creator we want to
pierce that veilus veil
we want to recognize that we are the
fish in the ocean
and we also want to celebrate the
uniqueness
of the fireworks there are in fact
beautiful artistic individuals
while they're also dream delusions
they're also expressions of infinity
that are contributing fantastically to
the planetary architectures and it's
important to celebrate them
and people that are smashing fast food
and gluttonous and lethargic
are not to be celebrated those are
people to be motivated
because ultimately that's us it is the
one
infinite creator expressing itself as a
lethargic
expression eating fast food
and so we are literally nudging
ourselves
to become motivated to a divine
transcendent noble aim
to become more
valuable to ourselves to our family to
our friends to the community to the
world
in the dualistic concession there is
value
you prefer clean water instead of dirty
water
you prefer benevolence instead of
malevolence
you prefer to not be hit with a hammer
on your knee and be unable to walk
prefer to watch a sunset
and there is individuation that's how
infinity expresses itself like sri
aurobindo
said diversity and oneness is the
mathematics of the infinite
oneness is the non-duality not two
already perfect already whole
the dualistic concession is
that there is a veilless veil to pierce
there is an eternal
shared awareness to recognize
there is the architecting of planetary
prosperity to do
and the diversity part of that diversity
in oneness
is the individuation it's the expression
of infinity
through the unique expressions
artistically
of individuals that are ultimately
dreamed in illusory
and yet are their own unique expressions
their
fireworks and to congratulate and
applaud the ones
that are maximizing the most planetary
well-being
and to help uplift and maximize human
potential for
everybody else to be shared equity
owners in the growing pie
to also understand scientifically how to
leverage decentralization and
cryptocurrencies and smart contracts and
tokenomics
to make it so that we can all be
inclusive stakeholders
is critical and if you're just being
told
that there's nothing to seek there's
nothing to do why would you care at
all about the code of life why would you
care at all about dna and biotech
why would you care at all about
neuroscience
and the chemoelectroconnectomics why
would you care at
all about helping the billion people on
the planet
make easier access to clean water and
food and shelter and electricity and
sustainability
education and health care
you have to recognize the simultaneity
non-duality i am already the fish in the
ocean i am already
infinity infinity literally can't be
found because i'm already
it done period got it
duality
infinity can be found if i'm a
contracted finite separate biologic
egoic entity that's contracted
that's seeking peace and happiness
externally
i don't know infinity
it knows me i don't know it
the awareness does not know itself
that's what the greeks meant by know
thyself
the top of the temple of apollo at
delphi 2 500 years ago know thyself
that means to turn inward like in the
parable of the prodigal son
that means becoming aware of awareness
like saint francis of assisi said
recognizing the seer
that's what you're seeking as ramana
maharshi said god
is the seer that's
the dualism of vidya ignorance
versus
a
from that recognition of the
god-realized state of the one infinite
creator
you woo way like laozi said effortless
action
like confucius said ren like the greek
said virtue
moral excellence outward
maximizing everyone's prosperity in the
stream creation
because you know yourself as the one
infinite creator and if you don't know
yourself as that
then that's where all of the planetary
disharmony and suffering comes from
that's the most upstream problem is that
we don't know
ourselves we don't know ourselves as
infinity as eternity expressing itself
and the individuation
as well
you as an individual have a
responsibility
to undergo the process to eradicate
suffering
the roots that are deep in your own
psyche
that have been taught across the
planetary traditions
for thousands of years can be completely
ignored by the simple
teaching at assat song that there's
nothing for you to do
and then you're angry and then you're
miserable and you're frustrated
and you think that that's fine because
it's all non-dual anyway
there's more for you to do always
there's always more for you
to recognize to bathe more
and more in the oceanic infinitude that
you're already in
infinity can be found
contracted finite energy
can release it can relax
it can expand into its own infinitude
buddhahood remains and the individual
remains to be
celebrated while it's also recognized as
a dream delusion
recognize that this unit is a dream
delusion yet i also recognize that this
unit is expressing itself
as infinity as this character called
atlas that runs this simulation
channel in this dreamed creation
do you know how to hold those
simultaneously the non-dual the duel in
the individual
it's not that hard it's just boils down
to simultaneity
don't ever settle with just one
final concept recognize
that there are core concepts
that describe the nature of our true
metaphysics
that require the jedi-like
navigation to not just hear one
thing and be done there's nothing to
seek this is already whole
non-duality done but
also to be able to dive into
dualism and recognize that to be able to
dive into individuality
and recognize that again a dream
delusion
yet also a unique creative expression
it's already all perfect and yet there
is
amkara the identification with the ego
that seeks like in the parable of the
prodigal son
like rumi said the diamond that's
already around its neck
to god realize as ramana maharshi said
as the
most important service that you can
render humanity
the one thing the most important service
that you can render humanity
can be completely ignored by hearing
that there's nothing for me to seek
that's why it's so important to find
these nuances
in simultaneity
we'll be doing a lot more content like
this in the future
again infinity both can and can't be
found
simultaneity simultaneous simultaneous
simultaneity simultaneity
ultimately non-dual
and a dualistic concession and
individuation that is both dreamed
illusory and unique fireworks
this shit's not hard
it's all simultaneity it's all your
ability to hold
nuance it's all your ability to create a
conceptual lattice work
that actually has metaphysical truth
within it
and just hearing there's nothing for you
to put into a conceptual latticework
there's nothing for you to do
there's no buddhahood to attain you're
already that
and yet you egoically explode on your
family members
and your friends and strangers because
you don't know
the eternal shared awareness
you still have the roots of suffering
and misery
we're gonna do a lot more content on
this this is really really important and
especially
we had jason reza giorgiani recently on
the program and we were talking about
the breakaway civilization and things
like the new world order
and it's really important to recognize
that with this great reset
and with the
architecting of a breakaway civilization
this elysium style possibility space
that exists the more that you say that
there's nothing to seek there's nothing
to do
the less you are also undergoing the
process
of both god realization and also
architecting the maximizing of human
potential
collectively architecting peace
prosperity
happiness abundance well-being for all
so the exact counter to
the possibility space of the breakaway
civilization
is to god realize
and to architect abundance for everyone
and not to say that there's nothing to
do
there is both
the process of going inward and
undergoing the god realization that one
infinite creator
and then there's the process of
recognizing how to optimize
entrepreneurially and scientifically the
outward creative expression
as charlie munger said there's so much
to put into
this conceptual lattice work from the
key disciplines across the planet
and the younger you do that the more
compound interest you have moving
forward
simultaneity all of the nuance all
layers
all layers simultaneously the nuance
this is key simultaneity
is key as sri aurobindo said
as bentino massaro said true
simultaneity
non-dual dual individuation
infinity expresses itself
as diversity in oneness
that is the mathematics of the infinite
sri aurobindo
and the mother mira alfossa
true simultaneity infinity both
can and can't be found
you're already it and yet it remains for
you to recognize
it and it remains for you to
undergo buddhahood bodhisattva
the individual is both a dream delusion
and it's a unique creative firework
non-dual dual individuation
simultaneity i adore you so much
love you thank you
if the video brought you value give it a
like subscribe to the channel if you
haven't
leave a comment below would love to hear
from you share the video with other
people that you know this would resonate
with
it's critical simultaneity
join the channel for exclusive perks
every single dollar of revenue goes
directly into the actualization of all
our projects
help fuel the artists entrepreneur
spiritual leaders
in your communities that you believe in
around the world
go inward fully
all the way drill all the way to water
to the one infinite creator
to the god rely state to the
absolute realized state and have
wu effortless action outward identify
the core patterns in entrepreneurship
and science to maximize your unique
artistic expression outward
don't just stop at there's nothing to
seek
adore you infinitely we got this nuance
simultaneity it's key
true simultaneity
thank you